foreign
we are back hey a few weeks ago if you
remember if you listen to all the shows
um I had a call scheduled with a
firefighter and right before he came on
he got called to an actual fire and so
we rescheduled the call and he is here
what's up Neil how we doing brother
how you doing doctor thanks for your
time of course man thank you for your
time and thank you for taking care of
our communities when I'm sound asleep
and my kids are shot asleep I'm grateful
for you man
yeah I uh first and foremost I do need
to apologize I know it's a tough I put
you in a tough spot
um who literally was my neighbor
you're fighting fires I run my mouth on
a on a on a b-rated podcast the art our
job comparison is of no comparison
Kelly's like no this is an a this is not
an a this is yes it is I'm gonna say it
today this is a b at best thank you Neil
man you do your thing Neil and we'll
reschedule every single time we need to
so what's up man
I uh so I I called in a couple of weeks
ago uh when you're on the Dave Ramsey
Show and and I'm sorry I even called in
a little late on that show I wish we I
would have had a few more minutes to
talk because it does kind of concern
both of you uh if you will yeah um I I
followed the Dave Ramsey program
um we're doing well uh we've got a good
job we eliminated debt
um minus the mortgage and so as we
continued on that path what's happened
over the last two or three years because
of
um just this role that I play with the
fire department
um we've encountered a number of
children
um who have passed pass on scene and
unfortunately I've been on a lot of
those calls
um and so
as that has happened it's put me in this
mindset where I'll come home and the
kids will say and I have I have four
daughters which is just beautiful
wonderful and they'll say Hey Dad I
really want to see this or do that um I
want to go there and because I'm in this
mind frame um I I just kind of book it
and go and so I'm kind of breaking my
policy
with what I've done with my death
I've broken into a few of my
savings accounts and made sure that I
had that time and that memory with my
kids
and I I always tell so I beyond being a
firefighter I have a full-time job and I
tell my team when you before you come to
me I want you to ask yourself one
question is the house on fire or are we
out of coffee
keep it simple right and so at this
point I'm a little nervous with where
I'm at I feel like this fire is at the
incipient stage and uh I feel like it
could progress so I'm trying to head it
off and that's why I called I love that
man
um and I I I we I take so many calls on
this show and then also on that show
that very few of them stick with me long
term and yours did
in fact I took some time the following
day
um our call that we had together and if
you want to go back we'll link to that
call in the show notes here if you want
to go back and listen to the original
call I was on the show with Dave Ramsey
and you called in
brother I had in talking to you I had
some memories of some situations that I
hadn't thought about in years
and I got a little girl too and it was
like I I was I I had some time I just
been with myself right so let me ask you
a broader um zoom out picture here
the the picture you're painting is of a
guy
um
who has a lot going on
and a guy who is constantly being called
up for service to his family you're a
great father
you're a great husband
a great firefighter you're also a
business leader and you do good at that
and the one person that you've left off
the helping list is you
am I right or wrong
yeah I think I said the last time I'm
the guy you call for help not when I'm
not the one to call for help you know
right exactly yeah yeah
I forgot that I said that like most
firefighters
hey I just want to call it out what it
is
um most firefighters are told
if you have a problem come see your
supervisor go to your chain of command
and nobody in the world in that in a
first responder situation is going to go
tell their boss they're struggling with
anxiety or struggling with depression or
hey I've seen too many kids passed away
this month I can't do it I need to I
need a break can't do that because
they're gonna kick you off to death Duty
or They're Gonna Roll you all off of
Patrol they're gonna and so you just
gotta sit on it
or they give you some counselor that is
got a reporting line to some right so
you just say they so folks say nothing
and then you know the amount of First
Responders who are struggling with
substance abuse who cheat on their
spouses who are have all sorts of other
issues going on in their lives and I'm
convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
it's because they see this stuff all day
long and there's nowhere to go
and I'll you are too valuable to not
take care of my friend Neil
so my question how do you do that or
what let me tell us this why won't you
do that I'll just be super direct why
don't you do that
well sorry I had a chance to read your
book and one of the questions that you
pose early on
um like after World War II we have this
abundance of money and credit and people
were able to get what they want now they
could get it at an implant and that has
never really left our culture our
society
um and you pose the question why
and so I thought about that and I have
been and so
I think about
what if I lose this moment with my kids
and that's my Why by me to do this now I
need to make this memory now
because when we are doing something in
Florida or as a national park or
whatever
we're completely unplugged and we're
completely together but we're not that
when we're here at home when we're at
home we're running
why have you chosen that life
oh god um
why not we're Americans right there you
go
so you you run in this country I I I I I
know and
we've created worlds that we literally
have to escape from
we have I do everything
and we've created worlds that are so
abundant and so fast moving that we have
to pay more money to leave them
to get away from them
and that my friend is insane
yeah but here we are but here we are and
I don't
and I don't know what my next step is
because I since we've talked my kids sat
down and they talked about National Park
they were looking through this beautiful
books that we have and one of them said
I want to go to Glacier guess what
it's booked yep I've done that since
we've last talked yeah
and listen you know your kids know that
when you get to do something nice for
them it lights you up
and so they love it when dad's lit up
and so they're going to find cool things
that they like and bring them to Dad so
that Dad lights up and then they feel
like they're bonding in that
relationship
if you go to a bunch of water balloons
and after school today and it cost you a
dollar 59 at Walgreens
and after school today I don't know how
much balloons cost maybe it's five bucks
um you had them in buckets
and your daughters came home all four of
them and you said you guys got three
minutes to hide and it's game on
they would tell that story at your
funeral not the Glacier Park story
here's the thing
you're creating memories you're trying
to hedge against the fact that someday
something bad is going to happen to one
of your daughters
you're trying to hedge the fact that you
have seen these moms and dads that
cannot physically stand up because they
have fallen down at a crime scene
they've fallen down at a wreck scene
you've seen you probably helped pick
them up right
yeah you ever held a mom who just lost
her baby lost her kid yeah it's a
different hug isn't it
yeah you can't breathe it's a strange
hug if there's a strength that I was
caught off guard the first time a woman
was saw her kid who had died and turned
and I was just happened to be there and
grabbed me with a hug that was of such a
ferocity that I I was caught off guard
by it
I didn't know strength could come from
that small of a person
it was like a I'm falling catch me hug
right
yeah
you're trying to hedge against that by
spending a bunch of money you don't have
and creating hype and hoopla and and
smoke and fireworks
for four little girls that just really
want their dad
Dave mentioned that on time
I don't know I I
there are just so many distractions I
mean in your book you outline you know
how many how many devices do you have
how much time are you on that screen how
much time per day per week I I do I
think about that I consider that and
then I also I've even played the tough
guy like we're gonna shut down we are
going to take those devices we're gonna
play a board game
and we have we do that
but it's it's just it's not the
it's not the moment
that we have when when we're completely
disconnected when we are in a tent in
the middle of nowhere in the middle of a
park you there's no cell service there's
no nothing there's just us
and I I am desperately trying to
recreate that in my personal life and I
just don't know how to do it because it
we get those dings we hear the emails
like everything draws us and pulls us
away and then that's right what's your
other job what's your other job
so I um I'm a director at the largest
publishing firm in the country
I'm going to be super direct with you is
that cool
yeah
I have you're headed for an implosion my
brother
I have conversations with some of the
most intelligent people in the world and
listen beautiful job it is it is
and you also know that some of those
people are hyper hyper intelligent in
their Bonkers too
yeah I know right yeah so intelligence
gets you part of the way
um I'm gonna be super direct man you're
headed for an implosion you're headed
for a crash
I can hear it
you got on the treadmill and the
sucker's on 15 and it won't go any
higher and you can run no faster
and you don't know how to get off
and you're a QR killing it in your other
job
you're showing up in the middle of the
night doing gnarly things and you got
four dollars that you're trying to raise
and if you think about it the other way
maybe it's that those places that your
their daughters get you unplugged
finally
well this week in Georgia
sure someday flew home Wednesday
I was in meetings until 5 PM
and then we have drills every Wednesday
night until 10 o'clock
so what are you running for man what are
you running from Neil
um
I don't I don't think I'm running here's
the deal I I honestly God feel like my
my daytime job I love it because I feel
like I'm providing education to the
masses and we're doing a great job
because education is the way out for a
lot of people who especially have
economic boundaries right
um in the evening I'm waiting for my
pager to go off because somebody in my
community is like my neighbor last week
or two weeks ago they needed help I can
help I'm a helping hand and I can do
this
you're going to be of no help to anybody
when you're dead
Neil
after your fourth drink again
you're too smart for your own good
and you're wrapped your you've wrapped
your pathology and altruism you're a
great human being
and you use that as an excuse to not sit
at home and be still
yeah I don't
argue that because you don't think you
have value in and of yourself your value
is only found in your utility
is there a problem with that
truly yes I mean yes
because at some point because at some
point Neil you can't be that guy that
shows up or at some point your daughter
is gonna have a wedding and you're gonna
get a pager number I left my brother's
wedding to go deal with a car accident
and I will go to the Grave with that one
because I screwed that up
I said my role in my community is more
important than looking my brother and
saying I honor you I'm gonna spend the
day with you
on one of your most happiest days of
your life I missed it man I screwed it
up
because I put all my worth in this thing
that I do for other people
and I had taken had no worth in my
brother just wants me to sit by him at
his wedding and say this is incredible
let's dance and eat
I missed it
and the more we think that our only
values and what we do
the more we just Chase more things to do
and we get push that thing more and more
and more and more and more you're
talking to a dude with two phds man I
didn't get that because I'm super smart
I get that because I was running for
myself
and while I was getting a PhD I was
working full-time as a dean of students
at a law school and I was also running
crisis calls in the middle of the night
I know I read are you saying absolutely
because I missed my son's childhood
I've got some great stories and I've got
some great experiences and I helped a
lot of people
and I missed some things that I could
never get back
well let me ask you this
how do we move forward from here I am
so ingrained in what I do
and I have a team of eight that
call and I and my team unfortunately I I
kind of have a unique circumstance with
my full-time job because I have a rep
down in Florida in Orlando and I also
have a rep that's up in Spokane so I am
going from
seven until seven per se Neil you're and
I'm listening someone's ingrained in all
this you're not engaged you're a
prisoner
you're a prisoner and your body tells
you the only way we can be free is on a
mountain with no cell service
man but it is beautiful there yeah it is
it's incredible it's amazing listen if
Dave Ramsey called me today and said hey
my buddy has uh a jet that's worth 10
million dollars and he's gonna sell it
and I talked him into selling it to you
for 2 million
it's a deal of a lifetime
I would have to say that's amazing dude
I would love a 10 million dollar jet
that I could buy for two million dollars
I don't have two million dollars so I'm
gonna have to pass
the Glacier National Park is is
breathtaking stunning can't breathe it's
so beautiful and we can't afford it
we've created a uh you you've created
your prisons locked from the inside dude
here's the here's here's the place to
start
um
I want you to spend some time with that
question and since and I want ask you to
write it down
what's Neil running from if if Neil
suddenly couldn't be a firefighter if
Neil suddenly lost his job as the book
publisher who is Neil
does that Neil have value
to his daughters to his wife
to his community
what I'll tell you is only because I
open up my hands and started trying to
be all stop trying to be all things to
all people only then could I truly show
up and be a gift
see here's the deal I always thought
that
there were these elements that people
had to fulfill throughout their life
that
it to continue on with this goal of this
dream this country what we're doing
our forefathers I mean it wasn't easy
like they there's there's time toil
blood that's all here
I want to continue that not just for me
but for everybody that comes behind me
that's fair and I do carry that weight I
carry that weight
earnestly I I wasn't in the military I
should probably should have been
um but
I carry that and I carry that
every day and I want to make sure that
everything I do that everything behind
me is is a smooth or a smoother password
and here's the deal I love that I love
that and uh I remember sitting down
having a private conversation with Jocko
and I talked for a while about that very
same thing and he told me John people
for because I was I was pushing him on
it like man you run and Gun you do all
this and this and this and he said
something that was really important for
me to hear
John men throughout all of human history
have left their families for months or
years at a time to go defend a land
and he was right that's true
the question you have to ask yourself is
if that's your path and that's your path
I'm not going to take your path from you
you want to die on the battlefield good
for you I'm I'm off go for it okay
that doesn't give license to be
irresponsible with your finances
so let me say this if you're going to
die on the battlefield
making the world better for everybody
else
um then go all the way and do it all
with integrity
and know that it's going to come at a
cost
you can't do all that stuff and not miss
games you can't do all that stuff and
not miss weddings you can do all that
stuff and have your wife going to bed by
herself a lot you can't do all those
things and go on all the family
vacations too
just can't yeah you got to choose
and if you're going to choose one you
got to make peace with the other
I think I'm here because I don't
I don't I don't want to keep going down
this path that's what I think I do I
agree with that I also know that in my
life I'm just speaking for me
when I start getting existential and
Global that's when my anxiety is at its
highest
and it is just looking for things to
spin up about
so I guess I'm hoping from you or asking
okay
praying
[Music]
um
I'm looking I mean you give me a Dave
Ramsey plan I will follow that day in
the day out step by step and we're going
to achieve and I did
how do I how do I like I don't know
how the heck you would even formulate a
plan for this scenario
what do I do I want you to get off the
phone and I want you to go to
psychologytoday.com
I don't want you to go through the list
of local counselors and psychologists in
your area
and just scroll down until you find one
that you read their little bio and think
this person is going to be this might be
the one for me I want you to make that
call
and when you sit down with the counselor
the psychologist and they say why are
you here
I want you to tell them I am an
executive I'm a firefighter and I saw
four dead children this month
and start there
and by the way if you want to be a real
gangster about it you can say
one of them where her name was Susan and
she was six
and one of us name was Stephen and he
was four he was wearing blue jeans let's
get real specific
that's where you start
and by the way you are uh
like
that's one of the truest marks of
Bravery I can I can account for
most people don't understand this but
it's it's easy to go run into an active
shooter situation when you're trained
for it
I don't say it's easy it becomes it
becomes part of your training you just
go right you just go right you're like
that too you see a wreck you just go I'm
driving down the road and there's a
wreck my wife will literally I'll pull
over the car and she'll just start
sliding over in the driver's seat
because she knows her husband's getting
out
she just knows that right and I'm not
even a trained firefighter
courage is when it's scary
and sitting down in front of another
person and saying I'm not okay that's
real scary to somebody who's everyone
comes to for the answers
is this something I can hide from my
wife nope
hey Neil here Neil she knows she knows
she's married to a uh as I put in the
book she's married to a taser
she knows
why are you so scared to tell her that
I'm not okay
because if I I'm Superman
that's why
she knows you're not
yeah I know she knows she thinks you're
dishonest man or worse she thinks she's
not trustworthy enough to be a part of
the parts that really hurt for you
she's she's laid some of this framework
here that led up to this conversation
and good for her she's a smart woman
you you love you some smarts
yeah
but I uh
I just I don't know when to call it and
that's right now that's what scares me
the most don't mate don't make an after
plan right now
the first plan is get out of the
building
so the first play like you're trying to
like the house is on fire and you're
trying to start drawing up architecture
plans for the rebuild get out
[Laughter]
that is a great analogy just call the
counselor call a psychologist and say I
need to talk
and you can say I don't buy into this
stuff I think this is for weak people
this is not for me
but here we are
I'm not all right
and here's the here's the beautiful part
when it all said and done
I actually work more hours than I used
to
crazy right
yeah I'm actually an infinitely better
dad and an infinitely better husband
I got more going on
the difference is those things that are
going on are not me trying to convince
myself that I've got worth and value
those things that are going on are now
things I can do freely because I'm
anchored into the Bedrock of my marriage
I'm anchored into the Bedrock of my
local community
and because I did that work
because I'm working hard to create a
non-anxious life where I'm not over
scheduled and overzealous and
overrunning and there's always
Electronics all the stuff that we've the
world we've created
because that's where the hard work is
now man I can go run if I need to do
something in the middle of the night and
show up somewhere weird I can go show up
some more weird that's fine I'll be
tired the next day that's cool because
my identity my Worth's not tied to it
yours is
and I'm gonna tell you right now it's
gonna be a hard road It's A Hard Road to
untangle all that it's gonna be messy
messy messy messy messy and
I have one thousand percent confidence
that you can get there and I'm proud of
you and I'm I'm grateful for you I will
be with you every step of the way call
me anytime
uh shoot me a direct message and I'll
I'll we can figure out a way to
communicate offline even if you need to
but I'll walk alongside you I can't be a
therapist or a counselor
um because I'm not even one of those at
all but I'll be willing to pitch in
where I can man your community needs you
and your family need you
and Neil needs you
grateful for you man